[Music]
hi everyone its Alicia Malone I'm back
with another Fandango indie movie Guide
where I give you a look at the smaller
films out in theaters and at home for
you to watch this weekend this week I
have three films based on drama within
couples or families let's start with
Wakefield starring Bryan Cranston my
wife's first call would be to my office
no he hadn't come in he didn't say
anything harsh Tillman Apothic this is a
really interesting movie it's based on a
short story and it's about a man who's a
father and a husband and he decides he
wants a break from his family life so he
hides out in the garage of his place at
the top where he can see through the
window into the kitchen and he decides
to stay there for a long time to see how
his family reacts to his disappearance
this is a dark comedy and Bryan Cranston
carries the movie
he's a very unlikable character but
Bryan Cranston himself is so likable
that you still want to follow this
character even though he seems very
ungrateful for his family and puts them
through a lot you can see Wakefield and
limited theaters this weekend thanks to
my family
I left myself
[Music]
unshackled I'll become the Howard
Wakefield that I was meant to be I
actually got to sit down with writer
director Robin so I called all the way
back at the Toronto International Film
Festival last year in September she
spoke all about being a woman in
Hollywood and she is a very inspiring
figure she wrote the screenplays for
Curious Case of Benjamin Button and for
Memoirs of a Geisha also wrote and
directed the Jane Austen book club here
is spotlight on women in films with
Robin spike or so Wakefield came from a
short story what was it about that short
story that you realized it could be a
good speech as opposed to making a short
film oh I saw so much potential in dr. a
short story I know it's hard to describe
exactly what it was but I felt a kind of
hook when I was reading it as if oh I
could just go in really deep here
there's a real story here and I think it
was just his character because he's
unlikable he's unselfish he's all the
things that we wouldn't look for in a
man but he he changes over the course of
it and the it's just these incremental
changes through small narrative events
and he's very different at the end and
so that was that was just something that
I you know it fascinated me he was
complex and I just wanted to go there
was this a project that you wanted to
direct from the staff that's been eight
years since you directed your last film
right I did a couple of other projects
that I've tried to get going in that
eight years but it's sort of typical for
female directors to take seven seven to
ten years really I mean there's been
Studies on this so I wasn't taking it
personally but I knew that I needed to
find something that I loved enough to
sort of push the rock up the hill again
do you see any progress with all the
conversation that is starting to happen
you know it's I think it's too early for
me to say that I would call it progress
but I would say that the conversation is
now in the open in a way that it was
almost bad manners
put it into the open a few years ago I
also noticed this year that when someone
has mostly female cast they almost feels
guilty if they don't have a female's
name somewhere on the directors list so
I look forward to that really being more
gender blind I think that it's sad it's
sad to see so much talent pushed to the
side for women and minorities when they
feel that you they have to code
something pink or blue before they let
you in for any aspiring female directors
out there what would be some advice you
could give them oh go and make your
movie yeah go make your movie
yep just get done get done yourself yes
do do whatever you can just make your
movie so nice it's really nice to touch
me thank you she is so fantastic alright
my next film about romance and drama is
called the commune it's by dutch
director Thomas Vinterberg these kind of
folks having a man's hair oh yeah yeah
these communities are coming DeVito
Bobby and I can take yesterday for
ecology this can take more so hungry for
something yeah
Along Came Thomas Vinterberg did the
hunt and also celebration this one is
not one of his best but it is still well
worth watching its set in 1970s Denmark
and it's about a married couple who
decide to start a commune full of
hippies lots of interesting characters
but this all puts a lot of pressure on
there are in relationship you give us
something simple so just ghosts of
yesterday don't even I am officer i
abided mystical higher on you don't
cream to be my agent
this is essentially a relationship drama
and it's pretty straightforward but it
has an emotional core to it and not
melodramatic at all it's a very sweet
movie so if you like Thomas Vinterberg
and you feel like something different
from his last couple of movies make sure
you check out the commune in limited
theaters this weekend oh yeah and I
wanted to talk about a film that's out
next week because I wanted to put this
on your radar and I'm going to be in can
and I'll be talking about the movies
I've seen can but I don't want you to
miss the Berlin Syndrome
so why did you come to Berlin you know
there's life experiences that people
talk about all the time
[Music]
this stars Teresa Palmer and it's
directed by Aussie Kate Shortland and
Teresa plays an Australian tourist in
Berlin who meets this guy he seems
really lovely they go out on a date
that's nice they bump into each other
again and then he locks her inside his
house this is a terrifying movie because
everything she does is something that I
would do I mean she meets this guy and
he seems really nice and she doesn't go
home with him straight away she's very
cautious she's very smart and he seems
quite charming and then he turns
completely and she is locked inside this
house it is heartbreaking to watch her
go through these emotions you said you
want to see Teresa Palmer is fantastic
in this role it's also nice to see her
you too Aussie accent it's a little bit
of a slow burn so it might test some
patience but if you can stick with it it
is a very satisfying movie very well
done and creepy it will stick with you
how do you think this is going three
films all about relationship dramas just
for you make sure you go to see
Wakefield with Bryan Cranston as the man
who leaves his family or Thomas
Vinterberg the commune all the very
creepy the Berlin Syndrome all about a
holiday fling gone horribly wrong next
week I will bring you all the action
from the Cannes Film Festival so make
sure you tune into that in the meantime
you can always check to me on twitter at
alicia malone and i'll see you soon
you